cette date vous la connaissez le 11 mai
fin du confinement annoncé par le
président de la république emmanuel
macron alors que la stratégie de
déconfinement se dessine peu à peu une
association basée à saint quentin en
yvelines soit apporté son expérience on
en parle avec jérôme andré bonsoir
bonsoir directeurs d'achats chef
prévention est une association nationale
de prévention de santé qui est basée à
trappes on le rappelle alors vous avez
développé un protocole de prévention de
réduction des risques et de dépistage de
masse ducobu 19 c'est un protocole et
qui s'adresse au public marginalisés qui
n'a pas accès aux soins et vous avez
aussi développer des solutions pour les
entreprises on précise qu à chaque
prévention à la longue expérience sur le
dépistage c'était normal aussi de vous
joindre à cet élan d'apporter votre
expérience
exactement parce que depuis donc 2011
on propose donc jusqu'à seize mille
tests par an au niveau donc de la région
ile-de-france des tests de dépistage
donc du vih et des donc des ist et nous
allons donc au plus près des populations
tant avec nos unités mobiles d'ailleurs
souvent vous menez d'ailleurs voir pour
relater les universités les cartes alors
là on le voit avec d'apporter donc les
tests au plus proche des populations ces
tests nous les avons nous avons
effectivement donc fait tester donc par
des laboratoires dont pasteur et on
attend donc le retour donc du cnr et il
convenait de pouvoir donc avoir le
retour des que du ministère de la santé
donc ce qu'on demande c'est
effectivement de pouvoir donc faire les
tests et de pouvoir donc les emmener au
plus proche des gens pour cela on a
réalisé donc un protocole retraite au
col qu'on ait des premiers à avoir noté
qu'on est en réalité dans ce protocole
international avec des signataires de
renault nous va donc nous permettent et
permettre à d'autres associatif de
pouvoir donc faire des tests commis 19
les tests qui sont effectivement donc
sur le corps un utérus et les français
donc les attendent
parce que plus que jamais les français
doit le savoir bon leur statut
sérologique avec un protocole vous
l'avez dit qui sera destiné à des
publics
auprès desquels vous intervenez
régulièrement il ya aussi des solutions
pour les entreprises qui ont été
imaginés par hf prévention exactement on
s'est associés bancables au cabinet donc
de renault en management et en
communication donc de crise l'idée c'est
d'aller au plus que au plus proche des
salariés de l'entreprise parce que ce
sont eux qui sont les véritables acteurs
de la relance économique et donc
apporter des tests mais aussi apporter
des nouvelles solutions de management va
permettre à ces entreprises de pouvoir
se relancer dans la continuité et de
manière complètement durable il était
nécessaire effectivement d'apporter des
solutions efficaces tant sur la santé
que sur le management est donc
aujourd'hui on a on se rencontre on a un
vrai besoin de pouvoir donc relancé à la
fois les entreprises c'est pour ça qu'on
a fait des propositions très concrètes à
valérie pécresse notamment que j'ai
rencontrés hier puisque valérie pécresse
a fait un don de 2000 mascara chef
prévention justement pour lancer donc
nos initiatives et puis on a fait une
proposition effectivement aussi et puis
à jean michel fourgous puisque hommes
comme comme vous le savez on est des
enfants donc de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et donc on a
aussi à coeur d'apporter à la fois des
solutions pour toutes les entreprises
donc à travers la france puisque le
kabyle les cabinets peuvent avoir cette
compétence là et puis d'apporter bien
sûr notre savoir faire sur 50 ans en eut
dit alors jean-michel fonde juge le
précise pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
président de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
othman d'un trou qui est aussi
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines également
conseiller régional juste sur le
protocole dont les dans les grandes
lignes à quoi à quoi ressemble-t-il ce
protocole eh bien vous avez déjà filmé
des tests de dépistage du vih avec hf
prévention n'en réalise 16 milles et ils
ont quasiment la même forme que les
tests donc on utilise habituellement
c'est à dire qu'en deux trois gouttes de
sang on va pouvoir donner donc avec une
certitude quasi aussi fiable qu en
laboratoire on va pouvoir dire aux gens
s'ils ont été mis en contact avec le
colis de 19
et si l'on développé ou non les
anticorps donc le protocole fait aussi
en sorte donc de dire comment vont se
dérouler donc ces tests ils vont déjà
pouvoir dont internet
de le mettre très rapidement dans des
unités mobiles un peu partout en france
alors vous avez été reçu par la
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse est ce que vous
demandez aujourd'hui à être reçu par
d'autres pouvoirs publics peut être au
niveau de l'état aussi exactement
puisque à chaque prévention comme vous
le savez nous sommes opérateurs avant
tout donc des agences régionales de
santé et donc du ministère de la santé
nous travaillons également avec d'autres
ministères mais donc et qui a très
normal qu'il y ait effectivement des
cellules de crise qui se sont à noter
même si nous connaissons les gens des
cellules de crise et qu'on leur fait des
recommandations
on a effectivement ces cellules de crise
en contact mais on trouverait normal que
dans le cadre de la démocratie en santé
des structures associatives telles que
la nôtre ou même des citoyens tout court
soit auditionné parce qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas faire effectivement donc une
campagne de stop and go c'est à dire on
confine les gens et puis on va les
laisser donc derrière ce re contaminée
pour ensuite dire qu'on va probablement
reconfirmer si on n'a pas les masques si
on n'a pas l'élégance
si on n'a pas de traitement et a
fortiori s'il n'ya pas donc deux tests
on va effectivement donc on demande à
être suis effectivement par les pouvoirs
publics
même si nous sommes en lien constant
avec les agences régionales de santé
d'ile-de-france qui sont un travail
extraordinaire ainsi que le ministère de
la santé on demande effectivement à ce
que nos solutions soit porté au plus
haut
on a fait des recommandations également
au ministère dont désarmés qui nous a
sollicités dans le cadre d'un appel à
projet est maintenant on demande
effectivement à ce que nos solutions
soient mises en place
les français veulent connaître leur
statut sérologique les entreprises
veulent être leur relance et c'est pour
ça qu'à chaque prévention propose à la
fois une solution concrète de
dépistables de de dépistage aussi fiable
qu en laboratoire et des packs
entreprise pour pouvoir donc relancer et
redynamiser donc le pays avec des
solutions qui aident à qui allie à la
fois le management de crise mais aussi
le domaine de la santé
d'où le fait qu'un chef prévention va
maintenant faire don de la prévention y
compris en entreprise